Mollie Kuramoto liable cattle guys make
sure that you try these supplements out
there very very good very healthy
natural and you can check the link in
the description box that is nature's
blend black seed oil and they have other
things as well yeah boy boy boy I hope
you enjoyed the videos because one thing
you see these 80 is doing is when they
try to refute these verses they
initially approached the Quran and they
tried reading it as if it was a
scientific textbook right and then they
take that verse with their particular
interpretation which is twisted and then
they try to match you up with the
science and say here's an inaccuracy and
and likewise apologists will do the
opposite so apologists will say well
look there's that there is a scope here
for interpretive correlation yeah so
let's let's put them let's make a
correlation between scientific fact and
the verse but making it as if this is
what the verse means 100% and and you've
closed the door now to all other
interpretations yes
which you can't do for many reasons a
lot of them I should use Prudential yeah
for example if we're talking about
abortion you know you can't just say
okay it's 40 days and that's it
there is 102 that is an opinion forty
days is an opinion but you can't just
close the door and that's it yeah so
it's important to realize that there's
there's a danger of closing doors
because of sight because of modern
science and also not to forego science
so there is a happy medium like we can
kind of try and strike I think also
clarify here is that what is the
objective of the quran guidances yeah so
allah revealed it as a guidance for
humanity and in particular those people
have talked about that that will benefit
from it yeah that being the case we know
the Quran is guidance and it's guiding
people to worship Allah towards back
towards their Creator right so the ayat
of the Quran are gonna be they are gonna
be speaking to people from this primary
perspective which is bringing people
back to Allah speaking to the human
being speak to the fitrah so worshiping
Allah is the primary focus of the you
know there's a beautiful verse in surah
al-hajj
we're lost paralysis Welli Alamelu Dena
ooh - Lila and the whole hakama Rebecca
Fatah beetle how cool ooh boom when
Allah Allah had in ladina a menorah last
year awesomest of him and this verse is
very powerful because it made me think
of kind of what you're talking about but
on a different level Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala says so that he was talking about
certain situation how he reveals
revelation Shaitaan tries to get
involved in a loss behind how that
deletes his intervention and so on so
forth but then he gives a reason he says
well yeah lamella Dina O'Toole I'm so
the people who have been given knowledge
know that is the truth from their Lord
for you min will be so that and then
they become believers of it were to meet
a local Imam and the hearts become
inclined to it were in Allah hell I had
in Ladino my less awesome assignment I
lost panna cotta is gonna guide the
people who believe in to the straight
path so this verse made me think that
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala he has he leaves
no Quran is multi-layered in that sense
yes he speaks to different people with
the same voice yes
and when I say voice he I'm not talking
about you know literal voice I'm talking
about in the same tone right so in
you've got in the same language
something which speaks to this person
and to that person
in other words the Quran is meant to
speak to the farm and the philosopher
yes
it's meant to speak to the student and
the scientist yes it's meant to speak to
the family man and you know I'm trying
to think of another F now way to make it
alliteration and Mabel can just say
physicist okay even though it's not an
official but what you see so allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala he the quran a
scientist could not look at the quran
say this is completely ridiculous yes
that's it can't happen
believe me I've looked at the Quran I
know it very well okay so you cannot say
it's ridiculous from a sign even a
modern scientific perspective you can't
and if you think it is like that is
because you have received some kind of
propaganda yes at the same time if you
have if you look at the Quran in an by
looking and saying okay well you know
it's also science like a scientist
book you'd not understood yeah we're
trying to be objective here because a
lot of penalty Allah says in the Quran
well enter Quran Allah him la talla moon
one of the worst sins is that you say
about Allah what you don't know
and the professor Solari said in the
hadith McKenna Bali and what time and
then Philemon whoever lies about me
intentionally they let him prepare see
in the Hellfire so we have to be when we
approach the Quran we have to be fair
objective and look at what the author
actually intended yes and I think you
touched really good point that it's the
happy medium unless speaking to all
people yet the whole of humanity who
then leaned a solace is your address for
the whole of humanity yeah but I think
tying in with this we also know as the
Quran is guidance specifically for the
people or the people that benefit from
me other people of taqwa yes right good
then what 13 well so understanding that
like I said even if a scientist
approaches it I would say like you said
they would they would not ridicule or
dismiss the Quran yeah if they really
honestly come to it yeah and that's the
key it's a lot elope we're making their
house if they're really looking for it
they'll see that's how it's an ancient
document but it's hitting all the right
chords from this perspective that it's
not deviating from what we have so it's
not a scientific textbook no yes but it
says things which I mean with what we
understand yeah and that's quite
powerfully and that projective yeah
that being said bro talking about people
of taqwa and humility that approach the
Quran and they will find guidance in it
we have the opposite end of the spectrum
to the some of the New Atheists and
atheists online that are attacking the
Quran now we've clarified this is not
you can't claim scientific miracles in
that type of sense in the Quran itself
and we've talked about extensively but
just briefly to touch upon it like we
said we're gonna talk about this video
put about put out by the rationality
wheels and genetically-modified skeptic
and they obviously tried in a refutation
of a video that some Muslim brothers put
out regarding the scientific marks on
the Quran hopefully this will get
Muslims to as to why we should a new
scientific miracles and highlight the
issues with it but some of the claims
that they make
how would you well let's listen you
example right and tell me you give me an
ala sister this is about two minutes
thirty seconds into the video
and he rationality rules is giving his
opinion regarding I am being sent down
iron is not natural to the earth it did
not form on the earth but came down to
earth from outer space scientists have
found that billions of years ago the
earth was stuck by meteorites these
meteorites were carrying iron from
distant stars which had exploded the
Quran says the following on the origin
of ayran we sent down iron with his
great inherent strength and its many
benefits for humankind the fact that
iron came down to earth from outer space
is something which could not be known by
the primitive science of the 7th century
now the first thing to be said about
this miracle is this point protestations
to the contrary people knew way before
the 7th century the iron comes from
meteorites for example when
approximately 1295 BC or 1900 years
before islam a hieroglyphic word
appeared that literally translates to
from the sky and it was applied to all
metallic iron from this time onwards
so using chronic logic i guess this
proves that a man RAR exists right ok I
think both both by the way bro he does
what they do is they do this throughout
the research the same approach yeah I
think that both arguments are
problematic that the argument of the
apologists Muslim apologists and the
argument of the atheist apologist and
they are both apologists yes so the
argument of the Muslim apologists is I
would say inconsistent if you look at
the whole Quran a lot of partisans will
are off the cut and then alaykum
Lieberson you worry so a tegu militia
well you best talk about that like a
fire Allah so Allah says we have sent
down for you clothes raymond a doorman
whatever you want to call it to kind of
cover yourselves and so on and so forth
now if you ask or if you look at the
face here does it mean allah subhanaw
taala literally sent down clothes yeah
you know it does not mean that or it
could mean that or could not mean that
but what I'm saying is that for for this
to work you have to suspend all
possibilities of majazi meanings or
possibilities of it meaning being a
metaphor or figurative speech even if
you don't believe that there's such a
thing as majestic or unlike even Tamiya
had the opinion that there's no such
thing as metaphor in the Quran it's it
still be some kind of idiom or
figurative expression yeah you'd have to
make sure you'd have to be a hundred
percent sure that when a lot of heart
Allah says in the Quran when general
Hadid we have sent down iron that he
does not mean by that we have provided
iron we have created I in this order and
you cannot dismiss that Allah could have
meant that hmm but you also could have
meant during the verse you quoted bro
yeah that lust sent down clothes
clothing all right but aligns the worst
by saying but the clothing of taqwa is
burning a very beautiful pearl equated
with aqua and so that the objective
there seems to be getting the human to
reflect over near the distinction
between a physical type of clothing and
that spiritual clothing yeah absolutely
so